support for denieth you gel on the
officers of one of germany's biggest
publishers but in Berlin's nearby
kreuzberg district an area where a lot
of Turkish people live that support
seems rather scarce most people here
have heard of the German Turkish
journalist but won't say a thing I'm not
talking I've got nothing more to say I'm
not going to answer your question why
not no thank you it seems many people
are scared they might end up criticizing
President 021 hunks many are afraid
bubble what of a voter one God has given
us only one life and it's one we need to
enjoy people at this teahouse in
Kreuzberg aren't prepared to criticize
her to one either because they've only
got positive things to say thermophilus
to leave you mean he's doing everything
right we've never had a president like
him her 21 supporters say he's boosted
the economy and people who run his
achievements down like Denise you gel
belong behind bars Jesus wanna see gigan
that man is against our country and
reports only bad things bad and wrong
fudge thus vegan that's why he's in
prisons can I slowly mine are mine it's
totally normal this is guns no much and
that's an opinion that prevails among
this Turkish area of Berlin despite
Germany's protections of press freedom
and access to critical media